[Music]
in this lecture we explore one of the
most important revolutions in the
history of humanity and even of our
planet the transition from foraging to
farming let me pose three questions to
you that anthropologists and
archaeologists have frankly struggled to
answer for more than a century why would
humans give up foraging a life way that
had successfully sustained them for
almost two hundred thousand years and
adopt agriculture did this happen all
over the world at the same time or did
some humans in just a few places adopt
farming and many others not and what has
the impact of the Agricultural
Revolution been on human life ways and
on the biosphere we have seen that
around 12,000 years ago humans were
living on all Earth's continents except
Antarctica
wherever they lived humans survive
through foraging by using collective
learning to invent a range of
technologies perfectly adapted to
different environments from the icy
world of the Arctic to the deserts of
Australia so collective learning and
technological innovation were clearly
going on but the small size of human
communities in the Old Stone Age and the
limited exchanges between them meant
that the pace of change had been slow
for close to two hundred millennia but
then something changed and it changed
quite quickly by eleven thousand five
hundred years ago new subsistence
technologies were beginning to appear in
certain regions of the planet
technologies that by enabling humans to
cultivate their own sources of food over
time gave humans access to more energy
and more resources this meant that not
only did human populations begin to
increase globally but in the new
agricultural zones humans were living in
larger and denser concentrations in new
types of communities such as villages
and towns increased densities like this
were frankly impossible during the
Paleolithic because foragers needed a
huge range of territory to support
themselves roughly two square kilometers
per person but farming can support many
more people in the same area one example
in
Bangladesh today agriculture can sustain
a population density of almost a
thousand people per square kilometre
where agriculture was adopted denser
populations appeared and the pace of
historical change began to speed up
putting humans on to a a new historical
pathway that led directly towards the
astonishing world of complex States and
civilizations but we're foraging
remained the dominant life way and
populations remained small and scattered
change was generally slower so this
meant that for the first time in human
history the pace of change began to vary
from region to region the transition to
agriculture was thus of such profound
significance that it clearly marks the
crossing of another threshold of
complexity by our species and indeed by
planet Earth the timing of the
transition was critical agriculture was
adopted early in parts of Africa Asia
much later in the Americas and the
Pacific and hardly at all in most of
Australasia and this had significant
implications for the appearance of
civilizations as we shall see to
understand why and where agriculture
appeared when it did let's consider how
foraging and farming differ
we've learned that foragers are very
good at finding new sources of energy by
spreading into new environmental niches
a process that we termed extensa
fication in contrast farmers largely
stay in one place so they have to find
ways to extract more energy from the
area of land that they have available a
process we call intensification foragers
live off a wide variety of animal and
plant species that are products of
natural selection farmers on the other
hand depend upon a much smaller number
of species and have learned to increase
their output through artificial
selection successful farming also
depends on the establishment of a strong
relationship between plants animals and
the human farmer an interaction that
evolves into a form of symbiosis a
biology term to describe species
codependence symbiosis is common in the
natural world where different species
have evolved to rely on each other for
food or for protection often becoming so
dependent that they can no longer
survive alone one example along the
Australian Great Barrier Reef the small
cleaner wrasse fish survives by cleaning
the gills and the teeth of other fish
some of which would probably eat the
small fish if it was not performing such
a useful tasks the wrasse lives off the
food it picks out of the mouths of other
fish while the latter depend upon the
dentist to keep their teeth and gills
clean another example of a symbiotic
relationship is that between honeypot
ants and Athens which are tiny insects
that feed on the SAP of plants the ants
domesticate the aphids by hurting and
milking them to obtain the honey jus
they produce but at the same time they
protect the aphids from predators and
help them reproduce doesn't this sound
very similar to farming like honeypot
ants humans have learned over the course
of 11,000 years to herd and manipulate
useful species like corn and cattle and
how to increase production of our
domestic 'its to support more of our own
species now humans obviously benefit
from this symbiotic relationship but so
to do our domesticated species which we
protect from predators and help
reproduce ensuring their success as a
species note though that the impact of
this relationship has been different for
each partner humans have changed
culturally because of domestication
leading to the invention of new
technologies and new life ways and the
evolution of our communities from small
foraging bands to complex interdependent
cities states and civilizations how
domestic 'its have changed genetically
often evolving into an entirely new
species let me give you two quick
examples teosinte the ancestor of modern
corn is in its natural state a small
weedy and not very nutritious plant
although it can survive in the wild
without human assistance over thousands
of generations american farmers turned
teo sente in two varieties of modern
corn a plant that is much larger and
more nutritious but that can no longer
reproduce
without human intervention the domestic
sheep is another example
the ancestry of all domestic sheep was
the mufon which still survives and wild
populations today in Turkey Iran
Selenia and Corsica the domestic sheep
is a lot less intelligent more docile
and virtually helpless compared to the
mouflon but because humans have
protected it and encouraged its
reproduction the modern sheep is
biologically much more numerous than its
wild ancestors in fact current estimates
are that the planet supports a global
population of over 1 billion sheep today
ok let's get back to the key questions
of where when and why the transition to
agriculture occurred it appear that this
was not an abrupt change the road from
gathering plants in the wild
then cultivating and finally
domesticating them was long and
convoluted geneticists working on plant
genomes have been crucial in unlocking
the the nuances of this transition as
they look for genetic evidence of
physical changes in species as a product
of domestication plant genomes show us
that humans who are harvesting and
eating wild cereals but thousands of
years before actual domestication began
a good example of this comes from the
archaeological site of Oh hallo - on the
southwest shore of the Sea of Galilee in
Israel which was first settled twenty
five thousand years ago probably by no
to thien's more than 10,000 years before
farming began archaeologists have found
evidence of up to ninety thousand
individual plants that were eaten by the
inhabitants but there is no genetic
evidence of any attempt at domestication
even though the remains of wheat and
barley on stone implements indicate that
the residents were grinding wild grains
to make flour and probably baking dough
in hearts the earliest sites and dates
for actual species domestication are
difficult to determine but there is
little doubt that the first successful
attempt at domesticated species was
undertaken by Paleolithic foragers and
that was the domestication of the dog
the oldest actual remains of a
gated dog have been dated to around
15,000 years ago the state comes from
the 2002 discovery of two dog skulls
found close beside a mammoth bone hut in
the Upper Paleolithic site of ELISA vici
one in central Russia in 2013 these
skulls were positively identified by DNA
sequencing as belonging to the Canis
lupus familiaris or dog family in 2015
researchers did an analysis of the
complete Myto genome sequences of 555
individual modern and ancient dogs this
research indicated that a significant
increase in the size of the population
had occurred around twenty three
thousand five hundred before present
leading them to conclude that this might
mark the actual date of dog
domestication the first successful
domestication of any species by humans
as Oxford Palio archaeologist Gregor
Larsen once famously put it the dog was
the first domesticate without dogs you
don't have any other domestication you
don't have civilization the
domestication of other species by early
farmers occurred gradually around the
world over long time periods this began
in Southwest Asia around 11,500 years
ago then in Northeast Africa perhaps a
thousand years later in East Asia at
least 9,000 years ago and eventually in
New Guinea in sub-saharan Africa in
South Asia and the Americas in the
millennia that followed so what prompted
the transition now the obvious answer
might be that as with the wheel some
creative individuals simply invented
farming and it works so well that
everyone else just copied it but one
problem with this theory is that
agriculture appeared separately in
different regions of the world that had
no contact with each other this
isolation is most probably true of China
and New Guinea and certainly is the case
in the Americas a world zone that was
geographically isolated from
afro-eurasia but we're very similar
processes of domestication occurred we
also know that
our culture was not necessarily seen as
a more attractive life way to foraging
as a better idea because foraging
persisted for millennia in close
proximity to early farming communities
particularly in northern Australia
agriculture was more physically
demanding than foraging also more
stressful farming was also less healthy
than foraging partly because farmers
narrowed the range of their food choices
and thus their nutritional intake and
also because that the repetitive
physical motions required of farmers
we're not as good for the body as the
more generalized physical activity of
hunting and gathering skeletal remains
also show that the early farmers were
not only subject to grade levels of
stress but also to new diseases many of
which spread from domesticated animals
to humans a problem we still face today
the adoption of farming actually
shortened human lifespans and increased
infant mortality rates amongst early
farming communities so the brilliant
idea theory the appearance of some
Paleolithic farming Einstein to explain
the emergence of Agriculture simply will
not work an alternative approach more
widely accepted today is to explain the
agricultural revolution as a a
step-by-step process in which conscious
human decision-making may have played
only a limited role critical to the
evolutionary not revolutionary model is
climate change and the emergence of
environmental conditions that
facilitated the transition coupled with
demographic pressure as a result of
increasing population densities in some
regions now that the last cycle of the
most recent Ice Age began around one
hundred and ten thousand years ago and
global temperatures plunge to their
coldest level between twenty one
thousand and seventeen thousand years
ago conditions were so cold that forests
disappeared and frigid tundra covered
much of the planet Spain seventeen
thousand years ago would have looked
more like Siberia
today under these conditions foraging
was the only survival strategy possible
for humans and this remained a situation
until the beginning of the Holocene
epoch
around eleven thousand seven hundred
years ago when the earth experienced a
rapid global warming at the end of the
last ice age the Holocene was not only
warmer and wetter but also more
climatically stable and as different
groups experimented with domestication
they increased in size relative to
foraging bands researcher Peter
Richardson argues that this increase in
group size led to intergroup competition
and this more or less forced communities
to adopt farming now building on the
work of Richardson and many other
specialists big history offers a
five-step model to try and explain the
origins of Agriculture the first step is
actually a precondition humans already
had a lot of the necessary knowledge and
skills for farming remember for almost
two hundred thousand years humans had
been endlessly manipulating other
species and landscapes to enhance our
food supply and to reduce our exposure
to predators so our foraging ancestors
were already pre adapted culturally to
manipulate the natural environment they
had an immense amount of knowledge of
our plants and animals and how to
protect useful species through not over
exploiting them and forages had also
demonstrated their ability to radically
transform their environments through
practices like firestick farming and the
hunting strategies that led to megafauna
extinctions step two is another
precondition really some animal and
plant species were also essentially pre
adapted as potential domestic oats now
by this I mean that some animals and
plants had evolved in a way that made
them more suitable for domestication
than others obviously not all animals
and plants are equal when it comes to
potential domestication for example of
the 150 or so species of land mammals on
the planet farmers have been able to
domesticate only 14 such species this is
because potential animal domesticates
have to meet some pretty demanding
criteria including rapid growth regular
birth rates herd mentality and a good
disposition of the
hundred thousand higher plants growing
on earth only about 100 have proven to
be reliable domesticates it was the
domestication in West Asia of three
cereals Emmer and einkorn wheat and
barley that effectively marked the
beginning of the transition from
foraging to farming Emmer wheat in
particular has significant genetic
advantages it can adapt to very diverse
environments it gives good yields from
poor soils it has the ability to rapidly
genetically diversify and its resistance
to certain fungal diseases like stem
rust is also important all of these
advantages coupled with the fact that
EMA has a reputation for baking good
bread explain its global success as a
domesticate geneticists have identified
several locations in southeastern Turkey
as the most probable places of origin of
wild Emmer wheat but the earliest
evidence of domesticated Emmer actually
comes from a site near Damascus in Syria
so it was perhaps from the damascus
valley or some other adjacent Fertile
Crescent early farming side that
domesticated week's spread initially
across Africa Asia and eventually all
around the world in 2012 farmers
produced 960 million metric tonnes of
wheat globally providing something like
20% of all the calories consumed by the
more than 7 billion humans alive that
year modern versions of weeds such as
durum and common have today almost
completely eclipsed the ancient on corn
and Emma grains which today are growing
only in a handful of mountainous regions
in Eurasia there were many such
promising potential domesticate species
11,000 years ago in Southwest Asia the
region had just the right climate
fertility and soils as well as a wide
suite of wild animal species growing and
grazing in the highlands of the Fertile
Crescent the abundant potential of the
Fertile Crescent is one obvious reason
why agriculture began there whereas the
the weedy and generally unmute Risha
snare of teosinte the ancestor to modern
corn
might be a reason for the much later
appearance of agriculture in the
Americas teosinte does not have large
ears of grain like Emmer and einkorn
wheat offering little nutritional return
for the early American farmer instead
teosinte had small nut like kernels
distributed in small feathery knobs over
the numerous tertiary branches plant
geneticists have been able to identify
the specific genes that had to be
modified by artificial selection to
enable teosinte to make the transition
to modern corn but it took early Native
American farmers many many generations
of selective breeding of teosinte for
these genetic changes to manifest
themselves delaying the widespread
availability of a nutritious and
successful grain crop in the American
world zone step three of the five step
model to explain the transition to
agriculture is that humans in certain
key regions of the globe were already
adopting less nomadic lifestyles and
becoming at least part time sedentary
archaeological evidence shows us that
sedentism began to increase in some
parts of the world from about 11,000
years ago there were two main reasons
for this climate change and population
pressure as climates became warmer and
wetter with the waning of the last ice
age in some areas there appeared regions
of natural abundance where large numbers
of humans settled it's no coincidence
that the biblical Garden of Eden was
probably located in Southwest Asia in
the Fertile Delta regions of the Tigris
and Euphrates the people who settled in
these regions were not farming just
living off the abundant natural fruits
of the land but this increased sedentism
eventually led to overpopulation because
sedentary peoples do not have the same
constraints on population growth that
nomadic peoples do migration further
contributed to the pressures of
overpopulation because many of these
same regions of abundance were also
natural funnels for human migration
Southwest Asia is the only conduit for
moving between Africa and Eurasia for
example just as migrants moving between
the two large American continents had to
pass through Mesoamerica and this at
least partly explains the large and
dense populations that eventually
settled in these regions certainly by
ten thousand years ago there is
archaeological evidence that these
inter-regional migrations had led to
localized population pressure which
force people to migrate through and
settle in smaller and smaller areas now
we learned in the context of the ancient
city of Jericho about communities that
as a result of climate change were able
to abandon nomadism and adopt sedentism
while still pursuing hunter-gathering
life ways such communities are termed a
fluid foragers foragers who have access
to sufficient resources that they can
settle down and become said enticed
evidence of affluent foraging has also
been found in many other parts of the
world including Australia for example
the gunda Tomorrow People of Southeast
Australia abandoned full-time nomadism
and settle down to build fish wares to
farm eels and to live in sedentary
villages nearby but it is intriguing
that despite this affluent foraging
LifeWay and the relative proximity of
northern Australia to agriculturalists
in New Guinea and nearby islands
Australian Aboriginals never made the
transition to agriculture the most
likely explanation for this is that
Australian Aboriginals lived in a land
of relative plenty and with such an
abundance of resources there was simply
no attraction in abandoning a successful
nomadic life way for more demanding or
stressful life way based on the
cultivation of domesticates but you
remember that the most significant
affluent foraging communities of West
Asia were the Natufian who began
occupying the Western Fertile Crescent
that is present-day Israel Jordan
Lebanon and Syria from about 14,000
years ago the two fient archaeological
sites like einmal aha
in Israel demonstrate that their dye
consisted mainly of harvested
and prepared while cereal grains eaten
as barley gruel and wheat flatbread I'm
mulatto also demonstrates that the
adoption of sedentism led to increased
population densities its population of
perhaps two to three hundred people
small by today's standards of course
made it perhaps one of the largest
sedentary communities that had ever
existed on the planet to that point in
time because of affluent foraging then
particularly in the Fertile Crescent
population pressures resulting from
sedentism and continuing migration
forced human communities into smaller
and smaller territories by thirteen
thousand BP forages were occupying a
wide range of environmental niches all
over the planet and in some cases these
niches could not support increased
populations as Peter Richardson's
intergroup competition model indicates
these groups were forced to try and feed
themselves off rapidly diminishing
parcels of land and with further
migration not really an option they
found themselves caught in what we call
the trap of sedentism step four in this
five-step process
remember foraging lifeways are
essentially nomadic in nature requiring
almost constant migration and
sustainably small populations imagine
how difficult it must have been for
migrating bands to support too many
babies or elderly group members with
reduced mobility survival in the
Paleolithic just thus demanded the use
of practices such as natural birth
control infanticide and silicide one
statistic on this some anthropologists
have argued that perhaps 50 percent of
all female newborn babies were killed by
their parents during the Paleolithic so
populations of nomadic foragers grew
very slowly but once human groups became
sedentary affluent foragers these
constraints on population growth simply
disappeared it was no longer necessary
to leave all folks behind and
communities were able to support more
children so populations grew amongst
affluent foraging groups this led
eventually to the problem of
overpopulation a problem that would be
even more acute if climate change made
affluent foraging less sustainable
certainly all the to fee incites provide
evidence of sedentism and increasingly
dense local populations suggesting that
there may eventually have been too many
people to support by affluent foraging
practices even at the level of
intensification practiced by the two
thien's
faced with increasing populations many
communities were left with few
alternative survival strategies because
of continuing climate change and the
resulting lack of space a return to a
nomadic foraging life way was impossible
and after many generations of affluent
foraging the skills of the nomadic
hunter-gatherer may well have been lost
the alternative was to concentrate on
increasing the productivity of the crops
and animals available to the community
by removing unwanted trees or plants
associated with weeding and
deforestation by planting tending and
harvesting desirable plant species
leading to domestication and by tending
and manipulating desirable and useful
animal species herding in other words
the only viable option available for
affluent foragers faced with
overpopulation pressure and climate
change was to intensify cultivation and
adopt farming and that's exactly what
appears to have happened at sites that
could support large populations such as
Jericho Jamo in northeastern Iraq and
Chapel Hill in Turkey the final step in
this model then step 5 is the adoption
of farming the only remaining survival
strategy available for these communities
this 5 step model works very well in
West Asia particularly the Fertile
Crescent but let's conclude this lecture
by seeing how well it applies to the
emergence of agriculture in other parts
of the world in central China the
arrival of warmer wetter weather
following the the waning of the Ice Age
gave hunter-gatherers access to herds of
wild cattle and sheep and to a range of
wild grasses that appeared in great
profusion particularly green foxtail
millet sites such as sugar WAN and shows
a town excavated in the fair
River Valley provide clear evidence that
the residents were pursuing affluent
foraging life ways still surviving
through hunting and gathering but
becoming said enticed evidence of
numerous sedentary Neolithic farming
villages begins appearing in the region
from about 6000 BCE notably Sushant and
polygon suggesting that these
communities were largely surviving
through the domestication of millet
8,000 years ago in southern China along
the middle reaches of the Yangtze River
a warming climate
soon after 8000 BCE led to an expansion
of lakes along the river valley which
Phyllis facilitated the spread of wild
rice to sites in particular have
provided evidence of the transition from
foraging to farming a cave at the Alton
hewan indicates that rice was probably
being collected in the wild by foragers
soon after 13,200 before present but
that had disappeared from the site
during the Younger Dryas cold snap when
the plant itself may have been forced to
retreat to the south just to survive
wild rice then returned to the valley as
the climate warmed again and was
apparently being domesticated by the
residents by at least 6000 BCE so Dale
Tong Hawaiian
along with the second major cave site at
Shan rendang provides indisputable
evidence of the increasing availability
of a domesticable crop species because
of climate change and of the adoption of
sedentary life ways by affluent foragers
which led inevitably to population
increases and the eventual domestication
of rice in the Neolithic era in North
Central and South America the same
general trend is found in the
archaeological record a climate related
increase in the availability of
different food sources led to increase
sedentism and subsequent population
pressure which in turn trapped humans
into having to adopt more labour
intensive cultivation practices and
eventually full-scale agriculture the
earliest crop species in the Americas
were squash followed later by common
beans and the chili pepper the Mexican
sites of Zahav Pilko and san andreas
appeared or been occupied long term by
affluent foragers who eventually made
the transfer
although the dates for this transition
and for the first evidence of
domestication remain difficult to pin
down in South America the tres ventanas
caves in the central highlands of Peru
provide the earliest evidence of potato
good and sweet potato in the diets diets
of affluent foragers living there the
appearance of the domesticated potato
has been dated to roughly 5500 BCE
although it's domestication status is
unclear because these species were also
growing in the wild in this beneficial
environmental niche once the shift from
affluent foraging to full-scale
agriculture was made virtually every
South American site indicates the rapid
development of complex sedentary
societies and increased population
densities particularly along the Pacific
coast so the five step model a process
driven by the critical prime movers of
climate change and population pressure
generally works well in explaining the
transition from foraging to farming
although there are some exceptions to
the model once humans were settled in
communities with increasing populations
the only viable option open to them to
feed themselves was intensified food
production from the land available and
once these communities completed this
complex transition from foraging to
farming human history suddenly found
itself spiraling along an entirely new
trajectory